il est avec nous pour son livre au delà
de la sphère de la chloroquine
applaudissements pour le professeur
didier raoult
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez vous remercie
on
professeur didier raoult que sa
réputation
merci vraiment merci d'être là
professeurs je suis très heureux de vous
rencontrer savais que j'étais je fais
partie de ceux qui vous ont toujours
défendu ce que je vois les choses c'est
que vous êtes à travailler énormément
que vous vous êtes vraiment ça vous êtes
un personnage incroyable moi je trouve
voilà j'adore votre façon voilà d'être
dans les émissions dans les interviews
vous est vrai et je suis très heureux de
vous voir ce soir voilà c'est une telle
rencontre en tout cas merci d'être là
votre me
parlait plus et c'est vrai que c'est un
livre coup de poing ou vraiment on
retrouve ce qu'on aime chez le
professeur house c'est à dire qui dit
les choses vraiment et vous démarrez
très vite dans le livre vous parlez très
vite de d2 vos détracteurs de toute la
violence que vous avez subi dès le début
de la crise sanitaire employé des mots
très forts pour parler vos détracteurs
charognards corbeau vous comparez
carelman certaines dénonciation de celle
de la seconde guerre mondiale vous dit à
l'occasion de mes déclarations puis de
mes publications sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine j'ai été pris dans un
tsunami avec un taux ronde insultes de
malveillance de menaces de plainte vous
l'avez mal vécu sa
non modérément modérément une série que
vous en parlait dans le livre et on se
dit c'est que c'est quelque chose que
vous aviez envie d'écrire de dos dire de
faire savoir une rien
si vous voulez cesser
ce que je voulais essayer d'écrire dans
ce livre c'est quelque chose que je
trouve étrange
c'est à dire etc etc et incompréhensible
et que je comprends toujours pas fait
comment il ya eu un tel déchaînement sur
la possible toxicité d'un truc a dû être
prescrit peut-être 5 milliard de fois et
ça il donc si on comment on peut penser
il ya eu 10 et tout ça a amené une
espèce de fantaisie délirante écrit par
cinq pieds nickelés dans le lent tête
que mots qu'on a appelé le land cette
guerre et ce truc là bloqué toutes les
effets thérapeutiques et avec ce
médicament et continua maintenant à voir
la trace de ce truc et au clic ce qui
est délirant j'arrive pas à comprendre
comment c'est possible que les gens
croient ça alors vous faites vous vous
posez la question pourquoi toute cette
haine vous fait un lien avec les
conflits d'intérêts que certains de vos
confrères auraient notamment le
professeur raphi vous dites vous je me
demandais donc quelle était la cause
d'une haine aussi rapide et aussi
brutale je ne sais pas si c'était la
raison mais en tout cas j'ai rapidement
réalisé qu ils paradent des collègues
infectiologues largement subventionnée
par l'industrie pharmaceutique
il était le premier français un de ceux
qui vous a critiqué où il a été condamné
bien sûr oui mais c'est j'ai
l'impression que aussi professeur donc
c'était plus contre vous j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya eu une jalousie
autour de vous et incroyable moi je l'aï
ressenti comme ça vraiment j'ai senti
que voilà il y avait vraiment dans le
dans le milieu médical il y avait des
programmes et il y avait plein de gens
qui étaient jaloux de vous qui disent il
prend trop de place vous l'avez ressenti
moi aussi ça ou pas du tout
vous savez ça fait longtemps que je joue
moi donc
vraiment ses dossiers depuis toujours
ouais c'est donc sa sébile avec avec la
crise sanitaire qui a eu avait été au
premier plan c'est vrai que vous êtes
devenu aujourd'hui vous êtes un des
français les plus en vue et vous êtes
devenus très très vite un des français
les plus en vue parce que c'est vrai que
vous étiez connu dans le milieu médical
y avait beaucoup de gens qui vous
connaissez mais c'est vrai qu'avec la
crise sanitaire vous êtes devenu j'aime
pas dire samyn star c'est vrai que non
mais c'est parce que
moi je trouve que c'est je pense que
c'est pas de la faute oui c'est ça je
pense que si vous voulez il ya quelque
chose là aussi qu'il faut analyser avec
avec calme et le calme reviendra c'est
qu'il ya une appétence pour le fait
d'essayer de dire aux gens ce que l'on
pensait vraiment donc il y a un vrai et
il ya eu un vrai problème et y compris
de dans l'interface avec un sérum de
journalistes avec sert donc de politique
il ya des gens qui disent il ne faut pas
le dire parce qu'ils vont comprendre de
travers et moi je suis un enseignant
depuis très longtemps et donc je pense
que les gens sont susceptibles
comprendre moi j'ai des discussions avec
les chauffeurs de taxi ce mon truc c'est
la cour sont aussi les choses oui puis
je vois qu'ils comprennent très bien ce
que je dis donc c'est pas la peine de
prendre tous les gens pour des imbéciles
alors des en fait il faut leur donner un
message simple parce qu'ils ont que joe
casey qui comprend pas ce qu'on dit je
sais pas ce que je pense je pense que
équipe usée je pense que c'est très non
seulement je pense passage mais en plus
je pense que c'est très très dangereux
parce que si vous mentez aux gens pour
leur faire croire que les choses sont
simples et comme très rapidement
on s'aperçoit que ce n'est pas vrai
petit à petit votre crédibilité diminué
personne n'a intérêt à ce que la
crédibilité des gens qui s'occupent des
choses disparaissent donc à vous faire
très attention avec ça je veux revenir
sur plein de choses hein dans le livre
parce que oui un truc qui m'a frappé
aussi dans l'ip ce que vous n'avez pas
peur d'être attaqué pour diffamation ce
que vous allez quand même fort non livre
parfois coûter moi je ne trouve pas tout
ce que je dis est factuel donc c'est ce
qui ma nature donc on vous retrouve dans
le livre c'est ce que les séries
actuelles voilà donc on retrouve votre
caractère oui oui c'est à dire que si
vous voulez je pense que concernant le
problème de l'industrie pharmaceutique
là aussi c'est un truc tout à fait
extraordinaire de voir que que
le rem des civières a été acheté pour en
acheter pour l'europe acheter pour un
milliard d'euros la veille du jour où
l'om est aisé que ça serve à rien donc
moi si vous posez pas de question qu'un
truc pareil on posait jamais donc il ya
vraiment des éléments de questions et
quand vous dites écoutez c'est parce que
vous êtes paranoïaque ce que je suis
tout sauf à renier jeu pas très méfiant
avant lui
de penser qu'il ya quelque chose qui
peut être organisé pour acheter pour un
milliard d'un produit qui sert à rien si
vous voulez c'est grave ex-travailleurs
enfin moi je pense que c'est ça de vrai
ça devrait intéresser un peu plus les
genres ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé là
c'est un peu étonnant quand on essaie de
vous faire taire professeur à vous
on vous avait reçu des pressions au oui
pouvait on peut l'écouter on m'a
convoqué au conseil de l'ordre on sait
discipline du conseil de l'ordre ça va
mais si on vous laisse je suis un grand
garçon ce que je dis est factuel et puis
honnêtement je pense que
là encore
vous savez c'est bien de connaître
l'histoire un des plus grands bonhommes
de parmi les plus grands bonhommes de
l'histoire il y avait un type s'appelle
georges mathé qui a inventé
l'immunothérapie des cancers qui est si
à la mode maintenant et en particulier
il a inventé de traiter les cancers de
la vessie et bénin les femmes qui
n'étaient pas invasif en injectant du
bcg on le fait toujours maintenant donc
c'est il a inventé ça et en 80 lazare
qui était le directeur de l'inserm a
décidé que tentant quand on nomme ses
directeurs et s'ils sont pris d'hybris
live décide de tout qui est un type
c'est ce qui s'est passé a lâché avec
vous oui oui c'est le directeur les uns
après les autres tentant s'imaginent
qu'ils vont pouvoir vous hors d'eau mais
si vous êtes là c'est que vous n'avez
pas l'habitude d'obéir et donc bien
foutu mater dehors qui était le type qui
avait une huitaine d'heures mais ensuite
je suis passé au conseil de l'ordre a
été rayé de l'ordre des médecins donc si
vous les y aider il ya des prédécesseurs
qu'il est digne d'imiter c'est pas très
grave donc il ya des gens qui sont
extrêmement bien non le souvenir qu'on a
balayé d un
autre qui s'éveille foot dehors qui est
un type est absolument remarquable
s'appelait dos et qui était le seul prix
nobel en activité en france on lui a
fermé son unité aussi parce que il
l'avait dirigé pendant douze ans avec
l'avare dit c'est ridicule c'est 12 ans
et n'iront ni 13 graves étaient peinés
d'être d'être est mis à l'écart non non
vous y est on dit
c'était pas tellement une question sous
les jets j'ai fait ce que je pensais
devoir faire au fur et à mesure que je
le faisais et puis voilà ces questions
alors vous critiquez aussi largement le
traitement médiatique du coc vit dedans
dans le livre pour vous c'est clair on
en a trop parlé nous on a mal parlé
parlé pendant huit heures par jour du
comice 19 relève d'un tour de force
inouïe on doit faire défiler toute une
quantité de gens il est impossible de
faire parler que ceux qui savent de quoi
ils parlent cela explique pourquoi de
mon point de vue ces défilés ressemblent
plus à des conversations de bistrot cas
de l'information c'est ce que vous dites
dans votre livre vous trouvez vraiment
qu'on en a trop fait sur la qualité
s'ils survivent vous pouvez pas parler
pendant huit heures par jour d'un truc
pareil c'est pas possible donc ou bien
alors vous en parler une fois vous
faites un truc mais arrêtez vous savez
bien qu'une part de l'information
maintenant c'est de la distraction ont
été donc c'est pour occuper pour
s'occuper et donc comme vous pouvez pas
trouver vraiment des sachant qu'ils
peuvent passer leur temps à faire ça
vous prenez des jambes moi je dis
souvent tout mère c'était déjà dans les
commissions enrichissement pour pouvoir
remplir les trous on prend des oisifs et
des parisiens les deux à la fois réparer
mais pas pour les parisiens est aussi
vrai si vous voulez vous qu'ils viennent
tous les jours sur un plateau raconté
d'édition voyez pas qu'on peut le faire
non
vous avez une préférence pour internet
je sais que vous faites très peu de
plateaux télé des remercie d'être là
parce que c'est vrai que je crois que
c'est le seul tokyo que vous avez fait
je crois oui c'est ça ben vous avez une
information comme quoi j'étais
célibataire mais
vous avez une préférence pour internet
la chaîne youtube de l'ia chu à plus de
500 milles abonnés et c'est vrai que moi
au 5e professeurs ont pas se mentir moi
je pourrais l'écouté des heures je
trouve qu'il est hypnotique est ce que
vous n'avez jamais pensé aussi à vous
dire je vais peut-être faire une
carrière télé web est-ce que vous avez
remonte pas du combat m'a proposé dans
tous les sens c'est ça oui mais c'est
pas moi c'est pas mon métier je suis
encore une fois je même surpris de ce
succès on a eu 100 millions de vues
c'est fou c'est 100 millions de vues 100
millions de vues donc ça veut dire
simplement après je sais pas quoi ça
répond très précisément piller le temps
le dira mais ça veut dire que ça répond
à un besoin que les gens ont d'une force
de l'information ou d'une source
d'information qui a un sens donc ce que
je vois c'est on avait commencé encore
une fois le bien à bien avant le coc vie
normale avait commencé cette chaîne mais
on a le droit d'être intelligent parce
que je trouve que le dire il faut pas le
dire parce que les gens vont comprendre
de 30 de travers est une insulte à
l'intelligence et donc je ne veux pas
faire ça donc on a le droit d'essayer de
faire comprendre des choses complexes en
les simplifiant si vous voulez tout en
restant dans la dent dans la
connaissance des étés jeu parce que
c'est la connaissance du moment sachant
que la connaissance ball mais on n'est
pas obligé de raconter des bobards pour
que les gens agissent comme vous voulez
vous croire ce que vous est il faut pas
trop les prendre pour des imbéciles
parce qu'ils croient ce qu'ils veulent
si vous s'intercaler l'extrait chiens
ils savent très bien faire le faire
alors vous venez aussi longuement sur
l'hydraulique le rock in eclipse apple
au delà de la sphère de la chloroquine
et toutes les polémiques de ce
traitement aujourd'hui vous en avait
parlé il ya quelques minutes mais la
molécule a été décriée notamment pour
les effets secondaires qu'elle pourrait
engendrer alors que vous avez dit que c
était prescrit des des milliards de fois
là dessus vous expliquer pour vous ces
effets ne peuvent apparaître que si on
prend la molécule trop longtemps les
gens qui restaient sur place et prenez
de la chloroquine en permanence ont
présenté un certain nombre de troubles
toxiques il ya l'accumulation de la
molécule l'accumulation dans la rétine
tout rendre aveugle mais celle ci ne se
produit jamais dans mon expérience avant
un an de traitement c'est important d'un
signal est aussi d'avis parce qu'il ya
peu de gens qui l'avaient retenu ça et
c'est vrai qu'on entend tout et
n'importe quoi sur l'hydroxyde
chloroquine
hydroxy chloroquine pour vous si elle
est bien gérée elle est sans danger ces
voix là c'est à huy pitch si vous voulez
un autre point qui m'a étonné c'est
toute cette gestion de verhoek cyclos
qui est étonnant il y a des effets
secondaires de hydroxyque look in à très
long terme c'est un médicament qui est
prescrit en france à l'année 2019 si je
me trompe pas il ya eu 35 millions de
comprimés qui ont été donnés sans
ordonnance en france c'est ça pour
traiter la polyarthrite rhumatoïde ou
lupus érythémateux disséminé d'accord
sur les maladies communes
je ne parle pas en afrique afrique
c'était le traitement du paludisme donc
je parle j'en ai pris quand j'étais
petit et tout le monde en prenait
il ya donc les gens prenaient 5,6
traitement par an c'est sur des périodes
courtes sur des périodes courtes non le
pulp ont pour le valais on prenait 100
en prophylaxie dont comprenait des doses
moins important que mon possible prendre
ça pendant deux ans surtout pour les
polyarthrite rhumatoïde et pour les u
puces et les gens prennent ça pendant
quatre ans cinq ans et donc il faut
surveiller l'accumulation dans la rétine
rouler au bout d'un an deux ans de
traitement trois ans traitement moi ce
traitement je les utilise et j'étais
premier l'utiliser pour une maladie
infectieuse en dehors du paludisme pour
des maladies pour lequel je suis
spécialiste depuis une trentaine
d'années et donc pour lesquels on traite
les malades pendant deux ans donc on
surveille la rétine mais entendu
ophtalmologie spécialisé va dedans qu'à
travailler avec nous et qui a jamais
trouvé le moins de problèmes mais encore
une fois il ya des doses nous pour
mettre au point des doses on a fait des
milliers de dosage donc ça fait 30 ans
qu'on connaissait on savait exactement
la dose qu'il fallait au nez et une des
choses qui est très étonnante aussi
c'est l'absence de choix de doses dans
les deux protocoles qui ont fait
référence est le protocole anglais le
protocole solidarity y en a un qui a
donné quatre fois la dose et l'autre qui
a donné deux tiers de la dose je ne sais
pas comment on comprend ça les pays qui
ont qui ont utilisé les dropkick lors
qu'ils se sont bien sortis ou pas du
tout
vous regardez moi je peux c'est chez les
serbes ont su inverser les divisions les
types à l'afrique me disent écoutez ça
va avancer seul traitement qu'on avait
c'est qu'ils allaient tous traités se
fait vraiment c'est aussi un succès dans
les pays qui l'ont qu'ils ont fait à
temps c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont pions oui
oui c'est à dire que c'est comme toutes
les maladies infectieuses avait une
infection à staphylocoque que vous la
traitez au stade de l'udu feront que de
l'aps et ou si vous la traitez au moment
du choc sceptique je sais pas exactement
la même chose est sûre il faut toujours
un et pourtant vous avez des
antibiotiques qui marchent voyez donc
qu'il y a il ya un moment où vous êtes
dans la stalle lésionnel ou un stade de
très très inflammatoires dans lequel ces
peluches et la qualité des soins qui va
faire la différence que l'or dans l'anti
infectieux que vous allez utiliser alors
vous en septembre série que vous étiez
au coeur de cette petite polémique vous
avez dû dire au revoir à l'ap-hm
assistance publique des hôpitaux de
marseille on en a parlé il ya un instant
vous aviez atteint la limite d'âge et
certains voulant profiter pour vous
écarter de les hacher la fondation que
vous aviez vous-même fondées c'est pour
ça je vous disais tout à l'heure ce que
vous avez été un petit peu triste que
c'est vous qui avez fondé
en corps une fois si vous voulez je je
je moi j'aime beaucoup l'histoire et
puis ma famille a passé son temps à me
raconter sa propre histoire qui était
franchement plus difficile que la mienne
avant ma grand-mère était déporté en
réseau avec tant que je vais pas pleurer
moi c'est en tout cas
d'accord moi ici se fait pas comme ça
vous êtes déçu on passe à autre chose
alors depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire c'est vrai qu'on vous a vu
partout on a fait la connaissance avec
ce professeur qui vraiment que tout le
monde voulait avoir sur les plateaux
tout le monde parlait que de vous moi je
m'en rappelle je faisais des émissions
sur vous pendant d aider des heures et
des heures les gens adorent et et c'est
vrai que ce qu'a fait aussi beaucoup
parler c'est votre franc-parler vous
êtes quelqu'un de très direct certains
vous le reproche qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui disent que vous les
négos surdimensionné et elissa et qui
prennent ça comme prétexte pour ne pas
vous aimez je suis pas je m'en fiche un
peu moi vous en fichez tas de ce qu'on
dit sur vous vraiment vraiment
vous regretter parfois certains mots
vous avez ou pas du tout
je ne vois pas non franchement non vous
avez énormément d'amis certainement dans
dans le métier qu'est-ce qui vous ont
dit quand ils vous ont vu comme ça
exploser médiatiquement
et votre famille même c'est vrai que ça
a dû être ça hein c'est incroyable ce
qu'ils aient eu un avant et un après
vous eh oui c'est étrange non que ça
vous a fait peur professeur avons pas du
tout bien vous êtes dit citrouille c'est
je trouve ça étrange mais je suis assez
encore une fois je je dis souvent ça je
m'excuse je me répète et jamais je suis
un stoïcien texte est en fait plus le
sim de moi même que le chercher des
miens celle des autres si vous voulez ça
va ça vient je la contrôlent pas j'ai
bien fait ça pour ça vous fait vous avez
fait au nom non non je crois que je
crois que je pense que je devais le
faire donc je crois que je vais le faire
donc j'ai fait et puis ça dépasse
beaucoup si vous voulez
c'est compliqué mais ça dépasse beaucoup
le le même combat où le même conflit
dans dont je pense qu'il est un problème
civilisationnel dépasse de très loin le
problème de la france spécifiquement il
est on est ce qui est très ce qui est un
problème c'est que on est dans une
époque on vit après une époque qui a
pensé que tous les problèmes que le le
progrès en particulier espérance de vie
serait permanent continuerait
continuerait je connais même des gens
qui pensaient qu'on avait jusqu'à 120
ans que ce que je croyais algérien et il
n'y a rien il ya une personne par donc
là
une personne si je le croyais exemple et
donc si vous voulez je pense que c'est
ce que ce qu'on appelle d'où une
asymptote c'est à dire que là on est
arrivé au plateau puis en a qui
recommencent à redescendre bien bien
mama les américains finissent à bas
c'est à dire que c'est vrai que ça
l'espérance de vie et c'est vrai que
c'est important de dire parce que ça
c'est un truc vraiment intéressant c'est
vrai que ça vous monte monte monte on
voit dans certains pays ces risques que
vous parlez vous parlez d'un chat c'est
à dire que sartre des sons et c'est vrai
que l'espérance de vie il ya plein de
gens qui disaient c'est vrai que ça ne
fane faire que monter et là on sent une
petite baisse comment vous expliquez ça
si vous voulez je crois qu'il ya en
réalité est sûre je pense qu'on a un
plateau sur le chauffeur dans ma
spécialité si vous êtes dans le 21e
siècle qu'il ya eu deux médicaments
nouveaux qui ont été inventés en tout
accord scellé sur lesquels il y en a
c'est le traitement de l'hépatite c avec
encore et puis un traitement du
paludisme donc c'est extrêmement rare il
s'est rien passé c'est le traitement qui
a été plus révolutionnaire de tous et
l'artesi mines qui est un extrait de
plantes découverte par une chercheuse
chinoise du temps de mao tsé toung et
donc qui correspond pas trop à l'image
qu'on se fait l'innovation thérapeutique
qui était utilisé depuis 2000 en un
comme extraites d'accord donc si vous
voulez le lead et on a une idée on a une
vision du monde qui a été bien sûr qui
est le résultat de ce qui s'est passé
depuis un peu plus d'un siècle on est
passé de 35 ans d'espérance de vie à
plus de 80 le quai qui a été en grande
partie épicerie morts et beaucoup de
progrès de l'hygiène et les vaccins il
ya eu les antibiotiques mais beaucoup
beaucoup de progrès thérapeutique mais
ces progrès thérapeutiques en
particulier chimiques se sont accumulés
c'est à dire que par rapport à il ya un
siècle on a un patrimoine moléculaire
absolument extraordinaire mais on a un
modèle qui n'est pas cohérent notre
modèle social n'est plus cohérent avec
le capital de molécules que nous avons
accumulée c'est à dire que notre modèle
delà de la modernisation est basé sur le
le brevet qui a été mis en place par
watt qui à 20 ans d'espérance de vie ça
a été un peu reculer maintenant pour
commencer à 20 ans après le début de la
mise en place la basique mais c'est
extrêmement courts et donc vous pouvez
pas dire que tout ce qui a été inventé
depuis 20 ans va le [ __ ] à la poubelle
que ça sert plus rien mais on n'a pas de
modèle économique pour tester sa pole
c'est un problème de la drogue thick
euros qui vous voyez bien on a eu des
gens qui ont utilisé des posologies
complètement aberrante parce que les
essais thérapeutiques sont gérés par
l'industrie c'est l'industrie qui
décident quelle va être la dose quand
vous décidez de faire ça pour faire la
dose il faut savoir comment on définit
il a d'autres et donc en réalité on a
vous avez la même chose avec hydroxyque
eurokin que vous avez eue pour
l'ivermectine aux etats-unis c'était
extraordinaire sont distincts
médicaments vétérinaires on donne 100
chevaux pour les guérir auraient été
victimes ces distribuer la dea des
sûretés des centaines de millions de
personnes pour pour des parasites et les
gosses pas des centaines de millions de
personnes en france et le traitement de
la gale donc si vous voulez epa et d'un
coup les gens ne connaissaient pas ça on
fait fuiter un truc sur internet est un
poison violent et vous savez pas comment
on arrête une chose comme ça comment on
fait pour dire aux gens pour ça il ya
des centaines de millions de lampes des
milliards deux entreprises faites pas
vous pouvez pas découvrir mais on est
dans un modèle comme ça et le la mmc
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché ne
est organisée d'une manière telle que
c'est l'industrie pharmaceutique et la
demande et donc quand vous dites écouté
puisque ce ce médicament n'est pas
toxique dans cette indication est qu on
le prescrit depuis des décennies
pourquoi voulez vous qu'il soit
techniquement une autre indication quel
est le sens de ça moi je ne comprends
pas le sens de sa et donc il ya une
vraie question je pense un problème si
villa sionnel on est une question où
notre monde a avancé avec l'idée de la
perpétuelle innovation moi je crois que
l'innovation est moins chimique
maintenant que technologique on peut
faire des choses technologiquement
extrêmement nouvelles qui permettront
d'avancer mais un exemple qui est
caricatural effectivement dans
l'espérance de vie c'est les états unis
où maintenant l'espérance de vie des
états unis est inférieure à celle de
cuba quand même ça fait six mois je
croyais pas ce fait moi aussi pour faire
aussi croyez pas encore été eux et ils
ont aucun médicament nouveau nom que les
vieux trucs mais ils ont une crise et
signe de communautaire qui fait que les
médecins vont à la maison que quand vous
cherchez à voir un médecin et vous
disent pas appeler le samu donc ils ont
dâ pratiques médicales de proximité que
vous avez dans beaucoup de pays en fait
et où la morosité était plus faible
parce que ont fait appel aux médecins et
pas au rêve d'une baguette magique avec
un médicament qui va sauver les gens
sans qu'ils aient besoin de voir des
médecins donc c'est pas vrai qu'on a on
a demandé aux personnes nous poser des
questions sur les réseaux alors il ya
cinq questions qui ressortent vraiment
la première ses bâtons devoir se faire
vacciner tous les six mois pour vous
on a vu
et on en a parlé quand on pense que ce
que certains croient voilà on venait de
pas vraiment un farouche opposant la
vaccination c'est ce que vous m'aviez
dit déjà le premier jour de la démission
mais ces derniers temps on parle
beaucoup de troisième dose de même de
quatrième dose c'est ce qu'expliquait
gabriela talent le porte parole du
gouvernement encore ce matin est ce
qu'on va devoir se faire vacciner tous
les six mois comme ça à l'air de se
profiler
jansen a d'abord pour vous rassurer
effectivement si vous étiez inquiet je
suis pas du tout j'ai fait moins dans ce
pays rembourser de vaccins qui était pas
rembourser avant que j'arrive d'accord
d'accord donc c'est une chose et
deuxièmement je trouve au contraire dans
ce pays on a un retard sur la
vaccination
pour la grippe chez les enfants qui est
une maladie qui peut être mortelle chez
les anciens rites et 38 par les enfants
sur la varicelle qui épie remboursés
depuis 20 ans aux états unis tepa votée
rembourser chez nous et puis sur
rotavirus qui est l'agent des gastro
entérite qui ni quand il est fait est
fait diminué de 30 % des
hospitalisations d'enfants donc tout ça
je les écris famille je les écris donc
c'était simplement pour les vaccins
comme pour le reste c'est de la
curiosité de le lire sur je ne vais pas
l'acheter je l'enverrai je dis la même
chose on peut pas leur dire vous êtes
pour ou contre les vaccins c'est une
question idiote il ya des vaccins c'est
savoir
pour qui voilà c'est ça à quel moment au
niveau des pas quel âge voilà c'est ça
veut dire que c'est une question qui est
une question médicale est d'ailleurs
vous voit vous m'aviez mais pris par
surprise et donc je vous ai pas répondu
je vais y répondre maintenant brigands
bay est ce que vous diriez 6
john pham venez vous demander
si l'on voulait vous accédez voilà après
les trois déjà ce que je dirais popo la
même jeune femme qui est encore une fois
parce que je crois qu'il reste un rôle
pour médecin alors que j'avais juste
quelqu'un en bonne santé qui à mon sens
un compte en voilà pour qui tout va des
biens ça dépend de la personne qui est
en face de moi si c'est une personne qui
est pas en surpoids ou obèses
vraiment vraiment obèse et malade je
dirais vaccinez vous parce que les gens
comme vous qui attrapent la maladie on
meurt d'accord accord un premier point
deuxièmement s'il ya quelqu'un qui dit
écoutez j'ai tellement peur d'être mal
du tout même vacciné je dirais écouter
vaccinez vous c'est quelqu'un qui dit
écoutez je suis terrifiée par ce vaccin
et j'ai peur d'avoir les effets
secondaires de médecin je dirais que de
2,2 du vaccin je veux dire écoutez pour
l'instant et tant que vous n'êtes pas
dans une situation épidémique c'est pas
nécessaire voyez donc soit chez chaque
personne on dit en fonction moi je crois
au conseil médical et je pense qu'un des
problèmes qu'ont avec le vaccin c'est
que on pense que l'état peut décider à
la place des médecins inquiets de la
situation de chacun moi je crois que la
situation dépend des uns et les autres
si quelqu'un j'ai dit les gens qui sont
les soignants qui sont au contact avec
des gens qui ont un risque d'avoir la
police ils ont beaucoup plus de raison
d'être vaccinées que les autres parce
que ils vont la trappe et donc en
particulier ceux qui sont très au
contact bien sûr donc si vous avez une
surexposition aux risques ou si vous
faites partie de la population qui
risque de faire une forme grave ou d'en
mourir vous avez un bénéfice à vous
faites maintenant pour vous répondre sur
sur le les les booster pour l'instant
c'est clair pour personne ça y est il
vient de sortir un papier de trois pages
dans l'ancien qui discutent là-dessus
ambiant finalement il faut pas le faire
il ya des gens qui disent non mais
finalement il faut faire à part pareil
pour la population à risque qui est la
population des gens qui allaient de
faire une forme grave d'accord mais
c'est vrai que ce que ça veut dire c'est
que l'efficacité du vaccin petit à petit
avec le temps a diminué bien plus courte
que ce qu'on imaginait d'accord masse
est ce un problème aussi alors moi de te
décrypte de ce que vous dites c'est que
une personne qui en
en excellente santé qui a peur du vaccin
ou lui dit pour l'instant attendus peu
oui pour une raison c'est que pour une
raison c'est que il ya il ya beaucoup
d'effets secondaires qui sont des effets
induits si vous voulez par par la peur
c'est sa blessure et donc c'est à dire
par la peur une fois qu'on s'est fait
injecter le voyez c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'effet nocebo si vous l'estimez ça fait
des années j'ai des crises a aussi et
bien longtemps si si quand on commence à
faire un vaccin on compare toujours à
fond on voit que ces injections d'eau
près du ciel dedans et donc vous mesurer
les effets immédiats dans la plupart des
cas les effets immédiats si vous faites
ça sur 1000 personnes les effets
immédiats ne sont pas différents donc le
problème de la cnas et que souvent il
faut en avoir fait cent mille deux cent
mille trois cent mille pour partie liée
à des effets secondaires graves quand
vous en faites me ou 2000 ou 5000 vous
ne voyez pas mais si vous regardez à
côté de ça avec non pas un placebo c'est
un aussi bon de 50 ans oui c'est le
contraire c'est le contraire si regardez
ce que ça fait bien vous verrez il ya
des gens qui ont de la fièvre ya des
gens qui ont des boutons il ya des gens
c'est psychologique oui oui c'est face
passion c'est très très bien analysé
maintenant les gens qui savent pas ça
c'est parce qu'ils sont ignorants
réflexion c'est bon les chercher chez
rsa ou les jo qui palabrent si vous
voulez de la récession bcc décrit un
très très beau papier la nature qui
montre exactement par ces on connaît le
médiateur chimiques de ça qu'elle a
collé aux pertes donc un médecin doit le
savoir ça il doit dire vous et vos mieux
et il vaut mieux éviter en tout cas s'il
le fait il doit expliquer à son patient
le rassurer suffisamment pour qu'il
n'est pas l'effet nocebo la corsa sas
induit aussi vous savez les gens vous à
la sophrologie à toutes sortes de
techniques de relaxation qui amène que
c'est effet nocebo disparaissent si on
les fait c'est évalué à vous qui voyez
donc c'est tout un protocole quoi il
faut pas le faire n'importe comment
alors on va parler de la vie les gens
qui s'évanouissaient mais moi si on
n'esquivera pas moi j'ai déjà on veut
dès qu'on me touche m'évanouir
la vaccination des enfants de moins de
12 ans n'est pas encore à l'ordre du
jour en france on en parle de plus en
plus un sujet qui divise énormément vous
en pensez quoi vous professeurs pour
l'instant au port pour le moins de 12
ans je crois pas du tout qui est de
consensus sérieuse sur le fait qu'il
fallait vacciner donc d'accord je suis
pas du tout convaincu parce que
le une des choses qui est très étonnante
dans cette épidémie qui n'est pas
vraiment étonnante si on creuse c'est
que en 2020 comme en 2021 la mortalité
chez les gens de moins de 45 ans et plus
basse que dans toutes les années
précédentes donc oui et c'est difficile
de dire quand même c'est une population
à risque au contraire le le ca si j'ai
un message de santé publique et la trad
arômes répéter répéter répéter que je
passais ma vie répéter c'est la
décontamination des ans des mains on a
eu les années à une chance incroyable on
n'a pas eu une infection respiratoire
grippale ni de virus respiratoire
syncytial ni de diarrhée et ça c'est
l'alcool sur les mains cette année c'est
reparti parce que je pense qu'on
n'oublie l'alcool sur les mains parce
que la dernière il y avait que l'alcool
sur les mains et que donc on a dit la
dynamique interne syriennes actives
inverse base de l'hygiène qui est de se
nettoyer les mains c'est café disparu
fait nettoyer les ventes aux enchères ou
et partout dans le monde nous on s'est
fait ce coupé parce qu'on voulait prêter
plus vite mais il ya eu 2 + papier
publié avant le nôtre sur la disparition
des maladies transmissibles banal
simplement dans le cadre de du coville
ou de lakovic
parler du sexe des anges c'est samedi
déjà mais il sait jamais exactement on
sait bien on va dire la copie d'ailleurs
à venir d'où la corrida lors parce que
il ya de plus en plus on entend de
nombreux scientifiques qui pensent que
le virus s'est échappé du laboratoire de
vue à 90 ans a de plus en plus ils
souvent pensez vous parce que c'est vrai
quand on en oublie en fait d'où il vient
à la base et c'est vrai qu'on n'y pense
pas non mais si si si vous voulez je
comprends bien mais tout et peut tout
envisager tout
la vie est pleine de surprises mais
globalement on fait assez peu crédible
parce que ça vous n'y croyez pas cette
thèse ça négligent laissez moi vous
expliquer avec plaisir voilà pour le
débit je le fait qu'il y a des milliers
de corona virus qui circule partout
c'est ça et que donc là l'imagination de
la nature dans les coronavirus n'a rien
à voir avec le mans par exemple j'ai
citées récemment une étude que moi même
j'ai découvert sur le tard sur la plus
belle est l'un des plus grands problèmes
de santé vétérinaire dans les élevages
de poules c'est la bronchite de la poule
c du lin coronavirus ça fait 20 ans
qu'ils essaient de trouver les vaccins
qui marchait je vous assure démarche peu
plus longtemps et ce alors que les
nôtres il vous dit que le virus s'y
était déjà essayé les nouvelles formes
de vaccins a annoncé et on arrive comme
à la grippe faire que les poules sont
revacciner tous les ans parce que ces
saisonniers en l'occurrence et donc tous
les ans on vaccine tout l'été vous ne
savez pas nier d'épidémie de la sttr
vacciner tous les ans en fait alors vous
les six mois c'est sûr tous les six mois
je pense qu on est susceptible de faire
des vaccins meilleur que ça d'accord
d'accord je pense qu'on peut faire mieux
alors vous allez expliquer même que le
clac au vide ou le covin existait déjà
ce virus au 19e siècle est ce que vous
nous expliquer non mais si vous voulez
on est en forme mais c'est vrai que
c'est bon on a nos noms pense que c'est
le lui-même on attendait un travail et
ça c'est mon collègue michel d'encours à
qui on a en brasse mais inventer
on a inventé en 97 70 ont parlé avec mes
cheveux des vidéos le la ce que
j'appelle la paléo microbiologiste et le
diagnostic des épidémies dues place et
donc on a commencé par faire le
diagnostic moléculaire on a identifié le
la cause de la mort du caravage par
exemple c'est très intéressant parce
qu'il a en tête la croisée des chemins
sur le magnat du problème des motards
dont sur le marbre on peut avoir des
problèmes également
ça fait beaucoup d'émotions en italie
parce que deux c'est par une sacrée et
de toucher ou caresser pas l'intérêt
c'est vrai qu'en italie ce importe qu à
la fin à la fin on dit voilà quand même
si c'est de ça qu'il est mort et puis et
puis donc on a travaillé on en parlait
tout à l'heure nous on a commencé par la
peste en 97 ça fait déjà on s'est battu
pendant 15 ans pour cette histoire donc
que dans lequel wikipedia l'idée qu'on
avait contaminé échos n'était pas vrai
et coach des fossés la science est comme
ça c'est conflictuelle la séance corps
quand vous vous dis des choses en plus
j'ai le malheur de sortir ça je savais
pas il ya deux best seller qui était
sorti et keffieh vraiment expliquant que
la fève la peste noire c'était une
fièvre hémorragique qui allie revenir
mon logis dont c'est la peste est
sûrement un peu d'antibiotiques ont
légué rick donc c'est c'est maintenant
non mon ami michel drancourt fait delà
de la sérologie toujours sur les dents
tout à fait sur les dents on a mit où on
a inventé de travailler sur la pulpe
dentaire pour faire le diagnostic des
maladies ancien parce que la pulpe
dentaire ça contient un peu de sens
quand les gens meurent ça se ferment et
donc il reste un peu de poudre de sang
est donc là dedans tiens il ya une
semaine extraordinaire mais on voit
encore on peut voir encore des globules
rouges dans des dents qui ont cinq
enfants non juste un croiseur on peut
regarder juste
fabrice rivière aujourd'hui et vous
passiez soir parce que vous le savez
j'ai je suis très admiratif du
professeur où je vais tout leur niveau
j'adorerais style et je sais que vous
aussi vous avez eu l'occasion de le
côtoyer vous allez là cette chance
qu'est ce que vous pourriez nous dire
sur lui juste en moi ce que j'aime chez
didier raoul c'est ce que ce que j'ai
aimé moi je suis un fervent partisan je
raconte une anecdote j'ai fait le tour
du monde pour aller rencontrer des
médecins j'ai toute une série de
reportages pour travailler mon épouse on
les a rencontré les médecins partout et
en fait le médecin le plus heureux qu'on
ait trouvé ils achètent eux retournent
au fin fond du maryland c'est un médecin
généraliste et qui disait chez moi j'ai
une mortalité maladie égale inférieur à
washington pourquoi parce qu'on suit les
patients individuellement de la
naissance à la mort on les suit
individuellement et en fait c'est ce que
didier rahout le plus grand scandale de
cette affaire duco vide sida le dire
n'allez pas chez le médecin c'est ça le
plus grand scandale on peut ne pas être
d'accord sur plein de choses mais depuis
quand on a une maladie il a parlé de
l'effet nocebo on a des gens qui sont
extrêmement angoissés à longueur de
journée avec huit heures non-stop où on
la fuit qui vont mourir et on leur dit
n'allez pas chez le médecin c'est quand
même le scandale des scandales et on
s'aperçoit que finalement tous ceux qui
sont allés chez le médecin tous ceux qui
ont été pris en charge et bien
effectivement ça va fonctionner enfants
dernier point sur la vaccination je
m'évertue à dire et pour avoir été dans
l'achat et naïm être battus contre les
vaccinodromes que la vaccination elle
aurait dû rester l'apanage du médecin
dans son cabinet dans un rapport
individuel aux patients ça n'est pas à
l'état de décider effectivement ce que
sont les médecins et comment ils le font
c'est ça que moi je retiens dira ould
dahoud ps qui dit didier houi savoir
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes heureux aujourd'hui
de dire oui non monsieur je suis moche
écoutez franchement c'est en plus j'ai
des raisons récente d'être très heureux
j'avais mon conseil scientifique la
semaine dernière qu'un conseil
scientifique y était et all-star ferland
géniaux c'est l'étape laisser des genres
et bourdais et les gens extraordinaires
de tous les coins ça s'est passé est
remarquablement est sorti alors c'était
un peu confidentiel mais au moins pour
les gens qui sont chez nous je peux le
dire est sorti vous savez il ya tous les
ans il ya des gens qui collectent toutes
les données et récitations font un
classement des 6000 mais des six mille
chercheurs toutes spécialités confondues
les plus cités du monde sur les dix
dernières années en france il n'y avait
pas beaucoup chaque année à diminuer il
y en a neuf dans les chu dans lequel je
suis qui sont passés
tombés
d'accord donc si vous voulez c'est le
seul institut qui autant de gens qui est
ce niveau de citations c'est pas moi
tout seul c'est des gens qui sont avec
moi on travaille ensemble donc tous les
jougs disant l'autre notre insu et
bénéficiaires gagnent de l'argent on a
lancé les start up here la moitié qui
ont marché que nous disions peut être
malheureux manière de dire en un jour je
sais pas d'abord en personne ne sait ce
que vous avez vous connaissez cette
parole victor hugo sur la peau les ans
cela venir à ta personne n'avait adieu
sir stirling connaît
la vérité avenue victor hugo pour
dire où je voudrais vous laisser le mot
de la faction vous avez envie de nous
dire ce soir parce que le livre je vous
le dis vraiment c'est je sais que gilles
là lui et c'est franchement fait
vaciller et moi j'avais des idées des
partis pris et vous vous êtes hyper
convaincant non mais vraiment faim parce
le livre de didier raoult on reconnaît
dilaudid ira loin qu'on aime voilà et
même ceux qui sont en panne je peux vous
dire et on apprend énormément de choses
dedans justin mais par le vrai oui parce
qu'ils reçoivent à ce kit vous êtes soin
de fleurs à ce ticket un élément
intéressant c'est qu'en fait ce que
didier raoul tout ce qu'il dit en fait
pour ce peuple juif et la santé publique
comme depuis 20 ans on a un vrai
problème aujourd'hui avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique
effectivement on a un vrai problème
quand tous les essais cliniques sont
menées par industrie et quand
concrètement à halle en europe vous avez
aujourd'hui un lobbying absolument
colossal auprès de l'agencé européenne
du médicament de l'industrie du
médicament au point que les mots
innovation ces mots d'innovation et je
précise mais précisément s'appelle le
phare mich c'est une nouvelle langue que
l'industrie effectivement a décidé de
mettre en place et a convaincu les
politiques de mettre en place et donc
moi ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
que le grand public sache effectivement
ce qui se passe quand même ces salles
avantages de cet arbre âge c'est
qu'enfin les choses sont dites jusqu'ici
c'est un petit cercle de 6h à le savoir
maintenant tout le monde le sait merci
professeur didier raoult je voudrais
vous remercier d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir
merci beaucoup